we don't mistreat our elders per se yes
we have a certain obsession with youth I
think every culture does but you know I
think the boomers are changing that and
the reason I say this is that the
50-plus Americans have the majority of
the disposable income in this country so
they've got the money they want to spend
it they're intelligent if you look in
the AARP magazine you'll see ads for
everything from computers to financial
services travel you name it cosmetics
and so as people age as the boomers get
older they're so strong and they're so
big and they're so important that
companies and the entertainment industry
and others if they insult older people
if they practice aging stereotypes
they'll do it at their own peril because
boomers are not going to tolerate that
you know there there are several points
of view with respect to treatment of
older people there is elder abuse in
this country it's kind of a hidden dark
dirty secret there is that without
question and a lot of it comes from
family members I mean so you always have
those kinds of you know negative aspects
of any society of any culture and we
have it too as far as people going into
nursing homes and sending their elders
off to nursing homes many many people
are caring for their loved ones at home
now it is true that if somebody has
Alzheimer's or some other disease it
becomes very very difficult to do that
and it is true that we are a mobile
society and so many of us are living
apart from our parents and for those
kinds of reasons there are people of
course who are in who have to go into
nursing homes and I think that other
countries are beginning to follow suit
as well
everybody would wish they could take
care of their loved one at home but it's
not always possible and so what we have
to do is balance home care
and institutional care and we have to
make sure that both of them are quality
quality experiences for older Americans
we need to work on that and I don't
think it's a necessarily a negative
thing that people have to go into
nursing homes just so the experience is
a good life